My name is Loren Brichter.
I invented pull-to-refresh.
I worked at Apple on
the original iPhone.
I wrote a programme
called Tweetie,
which was sold to Twitter,
and became the Twitter client
for the iPhone.
I worked on a game
called Letterpress.
And now, I'm one of the
creators of the Ragmask project.
And can you tell
me what that is?
What the Ragmask project is?
The Ragmask project is a set
of extremely simple, extremely
fast-to-manufacture
plans for face masks.
Why did you decide to do this?
We had a sewing machine.
And I tried following a
few of the plans online.
And I'm not an experienced
sewer by any stretch
of the imagination.
So we just developed
something that
was much simpler to create,
something that I could follow.
Like that was the
design constraint.
Could I do it?
This is one of my
first sewing projects.
I guess my philosophy is, I
can't think about something
without using my hands.
I mean, it's the same
with programming.
It's the same with fabric.
It's the same with wood.
It's the same with anything.
So if I can get some fabric in
my hands and a sewing machine,
and you basically
just like iterate
over and over and
over and over again,
eventually good ideas
will fall out of it.
And this particular
shape of mask
just happens to be
extremely easy to make.
And it fits pretty well.
It's not finished yet.
We have like two or three
more versions coming.
And I'm thinking of it more as
a technology product rather than
a garment.
We're literally versioning it.
We're up to version 2.2,
2.3 is coming tonight.
3.0 is coming next week.
And they're each going to
be refined in some way.
Do you have one of the
masks there, by any chance?
I do.
I don't have one of the
ones on the website now.
But I have one of the
ones that I'm working on.
We're trying to make it
even simpler to make.
Straps...
we can't find elastic.
Everyone's out of elastic.
You can't even buy
it online anymore.
So that's why we
call it a ragmask,
where literally,
you can make it out
of rags, dish towels,
sheets, old pillowcases.
So this one, where we're telling
people, it's not out yet,
but we basically just
put loops on the ends.
And then people can take
shoelaces, or anything else
they have.
We're going to deliver masks
without any straps at all,
and they're going to
supply their own straps.
And it saves us a lot
of time and material.
Can anyone make these masks?
And what do you
need to make them?
Really, all you need
is a needle and thread,
and some old fabric, any fabric.
A few people now have
hand-stitched them.
It takes a little bit longer.
If you have a sewing machine,
it goes a lot faster.
You really want to
wear any kind of mask.
Even if you don't have
a needle and thread,
there are tons of
designs out there.
The CDC just put one up.
You can fold up anything
with two rubber bands
and put it behind your ears.
I mean, that's more
effective than nothing.
How do you know that
these masks are effective?
A lot of the benefit
isn't necessarily
the filtration
ability of the mask.
Because you're not
filtering the virus itself.
You're filtering out
droplets, which are much,
much larger than the virus.
But you're reducing
the radius of aerosols
coming out of your mouth
and infecting one another.
We started the
project before the CDC
and the World
Health Organization
were recommending
widespread mask use.
So at this point
we're relatively
confident that they're
effective in some way.
On the wider public
perception of mask wearing,
can you talk a bit about that?
Whether you think
everyone should wear them
outside or not?
I feel like most of the people
watching this video probably
aren't wearing pants,
because everyone's at home.
Like, no one can tell if
I'm wearing pants right now.
But culturally, if you do
have to leave the house
- which you should avoid
- you would put on pants.
And I think the shift
that needs to happen
is if you put on your pants,
you should put on a mask.
And if you're the only
one wearing pants,
that's not enough.
Everyone else needs
to be wearing pants.
to be wearing a mask.
You should get weird looks
if you're not wearing a mask.
That's the way I think about it.